[Music]
then
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening my name is peter pat you
may know me as
screamy tambourine youtuber horror game
guy
but what a lot of people don't know
about me is that i'm actually a
certified pilot
it's something i haven't talked about so
i wanted today prove to you
a pilot reacting to flight simulator
we're gonna fly to sweden here
uh we're actually already in sweden uh
we're flying at bowen 747
this is uh something i'm well familiar
with
to disengage the parking brake uh there
we go
we are now going to increase the
throttle
there we go we should be moving forward
very gently i definitely know how to fly
a
plane so this should be no problem
especially in the home turf of sweden
just so we're clear i am a pilot all
right i will now take off
on my own volition not the video oh god
we're flying
oh my god i am scared
throttle control we want to maintain at
about 30
no throttle is not listening to me
look at the fjords beautiful
there we go we are maintaining a nice
altitude and speed
we're flying the boeing 77 now we're
going to retract the landing gear
uh we're dipping a little bit we're
going to now
climb slowly for the passenger sitting
in the back we're going to climb to
slowly to about 35 000 altitude
and from there it should be smooth
sailing my dudes
why can't i adjust the throttle this is
actually really concerning
i can't stop
[Music]
that's normal thank god this video has
to sponsor
[Music]
lord's mobile for the second time
bringing in the good stuff they're also
committed
to donating resources across the world
to help fight
kobe 19. if that is an epic i don't know
what
is they are donating over 3 million
medical supplies to help countries in
need
generous but they're also helping fellow
19 year olds
that's you a 50 000
giveaway am i mr beast or what cash
we're giving away 50 000
i don't even know this i'm reading this
right now that can i have the money
instead lord's mobile
all right we're giving it away to you
guys lord's mobile is the second most
relevant game of all time
it's the second best mobile strategy
game in the world you remember
you remember don't you wow angel that's
the lord's mobile
that's how good it is you gotta download
this time whoa
look at the t from that thing okay
that's actually pretty cool
god damn it the game has over 340
million players god
damn that's more subscribers and i
that's not fair
you can play it anytime anywhere anytime
anywhere did i mention anytime anywhere
you can play it anytime
anywhere download it right now and maybe
it will even become the most relevant
game you can pick your army troops
your formation that you want you're a
strategy guy i'm more of an
arrow formation kind of guy myself if
you're not arrow formation gang
click away from this video you do not
deserve 50 000 in cash
you create your city right you can make
alliances with other players
and destroy other enemies what's cool
about this game is that you can actually
be an [ __ ] in the game
towards other people that's how you know
it's a good game
for the 50 000 giveaway there's two ways
to win
click the link in the description step
one there's a might rank section
at the bottom below you increase your
mind by leveling up and building your
kingdom
the top 20 players wins a thousand
dollars in cash
so the top 20 are guaranteed and the
rest 30 will be picked at random
by the people that download in the
description but not only that you get a
three hundred and fifty dollars worth
pack by using my
link okay so use the link you get 350
dollars rate that's a lot of money you
will be notified if you want in the
lord's mobile in-game mail
now go out there and level up your
kingdom and get some hard-earned cash
get played to big games thank you lords
mobile for sponsoring this video
and helping the cause against the
coronavirus let's keep going with the
video
it's normal we're doing a little detour
here
and we're gonna rise up slowly here
we're gonna land in sweden we're not
really lined up with the airport but
that's
that's for noobs really we're coming in
hot
this is how you land baby this is how
you land in sweden
oh my god i'm actually nailing it i'm
late
we bounced up a little bit but that's
fine
stop damn it that was so good
fine i am a little rusty in my flying
skills i will admit this
we'll do a little practice this game is
so cool
i want to go to like uh different
locations in sweden where i
kind of grew up and stuff oh damn this
is so pretty so anywhere in the
the world is available in this game
which is really [ __ ] cool
god are you kidding me so we want to go
around here i think it's uh
where we want to go it's weird like i
know where it is i don't know how to fly
there
everything looks the same in sweden this
is so difficult it should be like here
if you go in this direction
holy sh what is that a golf course
that's gothenburg i found it
home we made it
yes what where am i
so this is all like based on satellite
images
wow it looks just like gothenburg where
the hell am i
is this gothic bird i don't think this
is gotham where
am i is sweden
i'm so confused dude look at the rainbow
glorious sweden we got rainbows
why do i not recognize anything
why do i not like what just happened
so even the weather is simulated from
real life satellites so
i'm gonna be flying over myself now
so this is the weather outside of
brighton where i am right now we're
gonna fly over the brighton
pier what the hell is happening why does
it sound like we're gonna white
[Music]
[Laughter]
you can't do me like that come on i'm a
pilot
i know how to do this okay don't ever
dump me i'm not lying
oh that's me and the boys right there
flying me and jack flying over brighton
let's go
i don't even know where i am okay so
that's what it looks like
there's brighton pier right there can we
slow down a bit all right let's look at
this
how real are we talking okay they did
model it that's pretty cool
all the oh my god
what okay oh my god there's the ugly
[ __ ] tower i want to actually crash
into it
whoever approved to build that [ __ ]
tower good job morons
these are victorian buildings so the
roof doesn't really look like
that damn that's so cool
all right you see my house is right
there oh i got the trick
i understand the trick it's happening
right there that's my house [ __ ] you
you pewdiepie
i felt good i'm still alive what what
i don't actually live there in case
someone actually thinks i'm gonna dox
myself for the
sake of a joke i want to fly over tokyo
that's gotta be cool right
oh you're right it's dark in tokyo right
now it's dark
guys let's go i'm so excited yo
we're flying over tokyo oh my god that
sounded like the most
cringy weeb coming ever i don't care
whoa
oh man it's so
[ __ ] massive it's insane
oh my god we can fly to mount fuji yeah
i'm so sad i can't japan is completely
shut down right now
no one is allowed to enter ah
it's emotional through a simulator and i
get feelings
let's fly to fujisan oh that's where i
live
right there that's my place you see it
if you could go anywhere in the world
right now where would you go i haven't
seen my parents in so long
we're gonna land on mount fuji this is
the last thing we're doing
i will complete this no matter what it
costs
boys where the [ __ ] am i i don't think
we're gonna see much
boys i need help man we could hit mount
fuji any second
boys i'm gonna be real i'm scared i
don't know if we can do this
there she is
i'm coming i'm coming yes yes we're
gonna land
oh it's happening oh god oh what just
happened
are you serious that's fine it's fine i
can recover i can recover
i recovered that's a golf course in
front of mount fuji that's so cool
i want to play there i'm coming flying
is easy i told you i'm a pilot bro
we're going to make a voice on the day i
proposed to marcia we actually went
nearby mount fuji in
hokkaido somewhere i remember i don't
know exactly where it is but it's nearby
and i remember seeing my
fuji that day it was such a magical god
damn you look like a long sexy beach
it's such a magical moment seeing this
amazing mountain
coming through the sky it's like a gray
weather day and here i am landing on you
in a video game
it's happening you can't stop me it's
happening
no no no
well we have just landed on mount fuji
oh let's fly from shoreham then
we'll fly over brian and we're going to
fly all the way
to [ __ ] london that's
gothenburg's airport
where i grew up one hour and 20. you
guys ready
i think this is the fastest one i have
so let's fly this one apparently they
stream some of the game for you
it's all based on like satellite footage
as well so you can actually see your own
house in the game
i think that's pretty dope and it's all
real time with the weather and you can
see other people
flying online and [ __ ] as well there's a
private jet which is the fastest one
it's a [ __ ] private jet isn't it all
right what do i do
parking brake engage no problem let me
just suggest
how we doing back there boys ready to go
back to sweden
you guys are so tiny you can't see you
but yeah you're in the back
this is captain pewdiepie we're gonna
have smooth
assistant pilot cyber sim we'll be
flying with this today
strat fasten your seat belts we're
taking off
to sweden oh god we're going a little
that's
let's pan out a little bit that's fine
what does that mean
itt i don't know what that is why does
everything keep blinking i'm
fine i'm doing fine oh god that does not
look fine never mind i see the horizon
now
stop blinking oh god that's that
that's fine like we're going to
we're going to die bros trust me guys
i've flown many planes before
i know what i'm doing oh is that
brighton that should be brighton right
there should we say hi
i know pewdiepie lives there all right
so where the [ __ ] is sweden then
that way follow the purple line okay
okay got it
light curve coming up there's brighton
holy [ __ ] you can cringe
i'm not changing to third person that's
cheating i'm in an aircraft for real
hold up let me stop that
there we go it's gonna make them shut up
sometimes retracting landing gear
oh god oh god we're a little shaky we're
a little shaky here it's fine someone
shut the baby up bro
[ __ ] babies back there god damn there
we go let's have a look outside what
have we got it's pewdiepie down there
you can see him down there it's probably
streaming or some [ __ ]
i can cringe ah that was easy
that was smooth no problem am i really
supposed to fly
over i feel like i need to we need to
get more altitude yeah let's get more
altitude
there's no wi-fi on board shut up you
guys are so [ __ ] needy
does this have a stereo
[Music]
uh we're losing course wait what oh
gosh oh god oh that's a little bit much
okay that's fine
that's fine we're just steering back to
direction
yeah all right all right all right we're
good we're good we're good
very good we're good how are we getting
it okay back there oh
you okay victor stop crying my god we're
flying
thank you there it is look at that what
a beautiful day to be flying to sweden
this place i'm out we're going to sweden
[ __ ]
can i get a little bit can i get a
coffee up here please scythe can you
give me a coffee
that's got to be altitude yeah all right
so we're 103
103 what asl is altitude oh i'm sorry
are you guys pilots
oh the left one is speed okay gotcha
thank you how the [ __ ] do you guys know
everything god damn
i'm supposed to be flying not you guys
you'll get snacks when it's your time
god damn [ __ ] cry babies doesn't want
to have with some whiskey
we got 700 whiskey on board if anyone is
interested
who needs autopilot when you're a
perfect pilot there's no clouds today
it's very clear sky [ __ ] yeah i'm
winning kind of feel like running out
just to see if i can see myself in real
life
is that autopilot on okay that's pretty
good now we can change
look at that that was a smooth takeoff
hope you enjoyed your flight with
pewdiepie airlines so far
we are on a steady course to sweden over
the
british fields apparently i don't even
know if we're going to sweden to be
honest
i feel like it's not that direction but
who knows
we'll now be serving snacks protein bars
and g fuel wait we're not going in the
right direction hold up
hold up we're a bit off course we'll
just stare that way
there we go it's a little shaky it's
gonna be a little shaky because we're
adjusting course
it's fine shakiness is normal shakiness
is good get used to it
uh we're actually a little we burnt a
lot of gas
so did i forget to remove the flaps how
do i
how do i oh god i got the flaps on oh
this is terrible
why didn't no one tell me about the
flaps bro there we go
oh that should be smoother what about
that those flaps are still out
you're not gonna die you're not gonna
die relax
you're one of those panicky people huh
we're gonna die there's a little bit of
turbulence
good betas uh what were they called
flaps f13 someone's at f13
i'm trusting you there's no f13 you
control
that does not exist there we go
there we go now we're oh that's so much
better
why did not tell me about that huh all
right we're we're fine
uh we're going a little fast according
to this but i think that just means
we're gonna go
you guys hear that that's fine that's
normal
don't listen to him how do we shut him
up which button i'm slowing down relax
we're gonna have to emergency lane at
the huckfield airport our landing gear
is broken there's no reason to be afraid
my dudes you're in safe hands we're
gonna
just do a quick little pit stop we're
gonna have to lose some people
because i think we're too heavy and we
don't have enough fuel we actually
haven't gone anywhere
why is the autopilot so bad as soon as i
press the autopilot we just start
dying you're in safe hands we're flying
to sweden and once we're there we're
gonna go to the yoyo championship
tournament
i think it'd be that stressful to just
[ __ ] fly i thought once you're in the
air it's easy
[Music]
what's the problem shot on how do i make
him shut up
oh oh now we're going faster
oh okay we're fine all right figured out
guys
no problem going very fast all of a
sudden jesus christ
think we'll be okay oh my god
what happened no
it's been an honor flying with you but
uh
now we'll take a break nothing happened
we did not crash
we did not crash what the [ __ ] was that
i killed everyone i'm so sorry tactical
landing
in mid-air no problem guys thank you for
flying
pewdiepie airlines we got a little bit
of rocky start there
but i know that we can't do it if you
just believe
with the power of believe we will fly to
sweden
zero deaths oh you guys didn't know that
was just assimilation now it's the real
thing
we had parachutes in the back all the
boys jumped out it was epic
it was just a simulation elon musk was
right oh [ __ ]
i can fly with a boeing oh i can't do
that that's too scary
all right get how many people are in
here eight thousand yeah
it's perfect we can fit eight thousand
in the boeing all right
big boy it is so we're flying from
gatwick this morning
london gatwick and we're going to fly
all the way to london to sweden
that's about an hour and 11 minutes with
the boeing
oh you can fly with live weather that's
so cool oh god
that's a big [ __ ] flight that's a big
uh
takeoff runway um this feels like a lot
of responsibility
hey guy you want to be my co-pilot okay
hey
wake up i need a co-pilot captain edgar
calling
all right captain edgar captain edgar
calling in
all right all right what do we need to
do we need to fly this thing
no problem all right yeah so i'm a
little sleepy i was out drinking last
night that's fine right
i did coke and heroin that's fine right
oh god this
[ __ ] thing is massive dude i've never
flown one of these before so i don't
know where all this stuff is you know
we are getting speed it's not very fast
though is it
taking off all right
all right oh god all right flaps
there we go there we go there we go
they're disengaged actually doing good
this time
i can feel it this is the one we're
doing much better this round
you feel free to take off your seat
belts and do whatever the [ __ ] you want
because i'm absolutely killing it here
we got to go to thirty thousand feet not
ten thousand my mouth off of
[ __ ] sake all right we're gonna climb
a little bit more gamers
fasten your seat belts that was a little
joke a little practical joke
we're at 146 so halfway up we gotta
double this altitude are you serious
where could we go with your space
i can't go to 30 000 that's way too high
i gotta climb more
i'm i'm pulling back ten percent muscle
increase there it is
damn we're high up [ __ ] all right this
is a little scary
you may now take off your seat belts
we'll be serving g fuel and snacks very
shortly
thank you oh god we're increasing
altitude
hold on one second now that we're up
here we can increase
all the engines boom we gotta get there
fast
my boys are hungry damn we're going fast
now
yeah 300 309 310 311
holy sh oh wait we're in the wrong
course
i gotta steer a little bit here you see
it there on
on the purple we gotta hit the purple
there it is we hit it perfectly
all right we might actually make it to
sweden holy [ __ ] dude
never oh god we're increasing a lot in
altitude actually oh there's another
airplane there
what up my dude we got a friend with us
on this flight
i think that's another live player have
we not left england yet
i'm pressing v but if that [ __ ] me over
i'm gonna be mad that's the map
yeah i know about the map look we're
flying this is the
no where the [ __ ] are we going
no oh god that's
that's completely the wrong direction
how do i turn around without people in
the back noticing that
i went the wrong way this is captain
speaking we're gonna do
a little air trick we're gonna do a
little nose dive
it's uh scythe's birthday he's never
done it before so we're doing it just uh
once
oh what the [ __ ] we almost hit our
airplane don't hit me all right
we're gonna do a little 180 trick the
g-furs
is a bit high people might pass out but
it's it's life's birthday we gotta
gotta do this there we go then clicking
stop that's always oh we did it we did
it we're on course
no one noticed a thing okay if anyone's
still awake
we'll now very shortly be serving g fuel
very soon let's all sing happy birthday
first time we're okay we're 44
fuel that should be enough to take us
there right autopilot is on look at that
oh my god hold look at that hdg hold
what is that that's autopilot isn't it
holy [ __ ] i think i we're gonna make it
boys
we're almost back where we started
gamers we have to fly perfectly from
here because otherwise we're gonna run
out of fuel but i think we got this
edgar with me he's going to land the
aircraft
right that girl you know how to do it
right that's your responsibility you
understand that right
hey wake up i need your wig you got to
lie in the aircraft
you understand me our life depend on
this how the passengers are you guys
awake
how are we doing back there they're
crying they're all crying
it's fine this is standard this is
standard procedure we have a support pet
here if anyone is crying
you can hug him flying with china if we
want to i have enough fuel for anything
now uh i can watch some tv shows some
pewdiepie from here
the question is are we going in the
right direction we are we're getting
there
we're cl we're close
we're almost we almost reached denmark
and we almost left the mainland we
haven't even left the mainland
is there anywhere to skip ahead whoa
don't fly next to me it's so uneasy [ __ ]
[ __ ]
no we're good on fuel now we barely burn
any fuel once we're in this at
altitude i think we can increase
throttle a little bit
whoa jesus so many planes are going with
us
stop by england look how many planes are
following us you look outside right now
we just left england
and we're going to sweden next we are
going in the right direction this time
which is always a plus unfortunately
we're going to be flying over denmark in
the moment
i know i don't like it either i cringe
just at the thought whoa
what are you doing stop stop what are
you doing
[ __ ] [ __ ] mad lads out here jesus
[Laughter]
what are you doing stop
see it could be worse it could be worse
dude snot he crashed he actually crashed
inside us
does this flight have connected brad oh
yeah we'll be making thank you brad
in eight hours it will be ready oh god
there's another boeing right next to us
what the f
scared me all right it's a good time to
flirt with the
flight attendant i'm a married man of
course i'm not going to do that but
scythe
sign my might want to do that look how
many planes are behind us
one two three four five six
you can't catch up i'm too fast
[ __ ]
we're making it we're at a good pace now
too i don't need flight school this is
easy
stop do not crash into do not all right
he crashed no
he made it he's fine good for you sir
jesus look at that flat earth than
theirs
you see that curve and what do you got
to say about that
hey don't fly so close [ __ ] crazy out
here
i'm flying here stop please stop
can a man fly this [ __ ] sweden
without getting stream snipe
this is how the vikings cross to denmark
we've done it once
we can do it again look how many people
are flying i love it
go to sweden boys me and the boys going
to sweden
yeah we're going to try and cross
denmark as quick as possible quick stop
at legoland question mark
no worries what is happening
stop i'm landing in sweden don't worry
about him i said it's all good
why is it doing that why is it doing
that
why is it doing that out of sight and
what is happening what is happening
all right what the [ __ ] is this thing
okay auto sounds good right
there we go oh oh
turn it off turn it off
turn it off
what just happened the autopilot hates
me where did everyone else go
how did i lose everyone we're dropping
altitude like [ __ ] crazy dude
how am i going so fast
no what even happened
can we pick off from there because i
really want to try and land god we were
close i'm doing that again i'm doing
that again not from the start
all right it's like nothing happened uh
pilot
blanked out for a second there we're
landing this [ __ ] thing in sweden
i don't care what it takes it's gonna
happen
zero deaths some of you landed in the
ocean
that's fine some of you jumped out
because you were scared but this plane
is gonna land
here we go just where we were picking up
just where we landed a little shitty
weather in sweden but it always is
this actually looks like when you're
landing in sweden that's pretty cool
oh my god [ __ ] [ __ ] stop you're
hella low mind man
we're even lower now
stop [ __ ] oh they found me again for
those of you never flown to sweden this
is what it looks like
got a bunch of islands and [ __ ] does
anyone see the airport
there it is holy [ __ ] okay we find it
okay uh
yeah we might have to make like a circle
around it's not turning
it's not turning it's not turning it's
not turn
it's it's not turning it's not
turn thank you for flying pewdiepie
airlines
we just safely landed a little bit
outside the airport
god damn it maybe we went a little too
slow
i thought you were supposed to be slow
for a landing here let me let me do that
again we gonna land this
look how many people are in that there
so
funny i did the job boss i landed the
airplane
oh my god we're literally flying over
the airport right now we're literally
[ __ ]
what's our altitude 9 000 you might feel
a little bit of g's here boys
it stops turning it locks up coming in
for landing coming in hot coming in hot
coming in high
here we go boys this is it thanks for
sticking with me all right cutting
cutting all throttle
no no like this come on boys
we're dipping no
so close i'm gonna do it i'm gonna land
this [ __ ] plane
up go up
go up
those are simulations all the ones we've
done so far
this is the real one use rudders to
steer really
oh that works pretty well oh
oh the rudders do not use the rudders
that was a troll there it is there it is
there's the airport
all right flaps flaps now
no don't dive too quick landing gear
let's go let's go
why am i dipping so fast why am i
dipping so fast
why am i dipping so fast that's not the
runway
thank you for flying pewdiepie airline
this has been my pleasure welcome to
gothenburg
thank you for watching this video i hope
this proves that i'm a pilot
once and for all like if you enjoyed
thank you for subscribing
see you guys next time children of
nine parts it's time to raise what was
once forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean